[Music]
only trust thyself and another shall not
betray thee
[Music]
the saddest thing about betrayal is that
it never comes from your enemies
[Music]
they talk of a man betraying his country
his friends his sweetheart
there must be a moral bond first
all a man can betray is his conscience
when someone betrays you
it is a reflection of their character
not yours
silence is a true friend who never
betrays
[Music]
those who don't know the value of
loyalty can never appreciate the cost of
betrayal
sometimes instead of being hurt you
should look at betrayal as a gift
it makes it that much easier to sweep it
up and toss it out with the rest of the
trash
betrayal can be extremely painful but
it's up to you how much that pain
damages you permanently
life is not about who's real to your
face
it's about who's real behind your back
when no one you know tells the truth you
learn to see under the surface
there is always a lesson to learn in
every betrayal
[Music]
betraying someone once can be a mistake
betraying someone twice is a choice
[Music]
the knives of betrayal and drama cut
deep in hurt
but they also trim away the nonsense and
reveal your true friends
for there to be betrayal there would
have to have been trust first
[Music]
breaking someone's trust is like
crumpling up a perfect piece of paper
you can smooth it over but it's never
going to be the same again
some people are willing to betray years
of friendship just to get a little bit
of the spotlight
if you do not express your own ideas if
you do not listen to your own being you
will have betrayed yourself
the worst mistake a man can make is to
betray a woman who actually supported
him when he was going through the worst
time of his life
[Music]
betrayal is common for men with no
conscience
[Music]
faithful are the wounds of a friend but
the kisses of an enemy are deceitful
[Music]
betray a friend and you'll often find
you have ruined yourself
[Music]
the betrayal of trust carries a heavy
taboo
[Music]
love comes to those who still hope after
disappointment who still believe after
betrayal
and who still love after they've been
hurt
[Music]
even the people who betray you are part
of the plan
[Music]
the real betrayal is forgetting yourself
when you care about someone you can't
just turn that off because you learn
they betrayed you
it is more shameful to distrust our
friends than to be deceived by them
[Music]
some of the most poisonous people come
disguised as friends
the worst kind of hurt is betrayal
because it means that someone will be
willing to hurt you just to make
themselves feel better
it is easier to forgive an enemy than to
forgive a friend
[Music]
betrayal doesn't only break your heart
but also darkens your soul
keep talking about me behind my back and
watch god keep blessing me in front of
your face
love and marriage are wonderful arenas
in which to place a character
there is nothing worse than betraying
yourself
[Music]
betrayal is so emotionally charged
because the act of betrayal violates a
couple's core agreement
the promise to care for each other and
keep each other safe
beware the person who stabs you and then
tells the world they're bleeding
they can betray me but i choose not to
betray my peace of mind
[Music]
most friendship is feigning
most love mere folly
[Music]
betray a friend and you'll often find
you have ruined yourself
i'm mature enough to forgive you but i'm
not dumb enough to trust you again
sometimes the person you take a bullet
for is pulling the trigger
there's no black and no white just
shades of gray
but small betrayals lead to bigger ones
and morality is eroded
[Music]
betrayal is never easy to handle and
there is no right way to accept it
if you're betrayed release
disappointment at once that way
bitterness has no time to take root
an honest enemy is better than a false
friend
when in doubt pay more attention to what
people do and less attention to what
they say
[Music]
stab the body and it heals injure the
heart and the wound lasts a lifetime
[Music]
nothing hurts more than being
disappointed by the one person you
thought would never hurt you
love never betrays people do
[Music]
forgive yourself for the blindness that
placed you in the path of those who
betrayed you
sometimes a good heart can't see the bad
[Music]
don't trust a wife who doesn't trust you
[Music]
the one who forgave the betrayal of his
wife soon will realize she is no longer
his wife
[Music]
[Music]
you